one shouldn't take crazy stuff seriously
because there's nothing normal about
crazy stuff and you don't want to
pretend there is problem is this is the
Golden Age of crazy yeah this in DC
Jesus this in California this in London
and now in Boston State Democratic Rep
Dan Hahn introduces a bill that makes
using the word let's say used to
describe a pregnant dog punishable with
six months of jail time now before you
dismiss this as piffle let's not forget
it made it this far from a citizen to a
governmental body in a large city in a
large state crazy is like mold the
longer you look away the bigger it gets
some people will defend this bill saying
hey while I don't agree I understand
words can hurt well no this is what
happens when you pretend crazy is never
gonna get out of its crazy little box
but crazies out of the box which was the
college campus then the California
Legislature now it's spread to media to
HR to government when saying people go
for shelter the crazy comes out the
socialist runs for president words get
banned secret cabal's undermine a duly
elected government egged on by the media
and they call you crazy no real crazy is
on the March
crazy wants to turn math into gibberish
it wants to ditch school grades it
blocks people from going to work it
throws fluid on politicians it mobs
people at their houses spits and punches
at those for wearing hats can [ __ ]
spokes is to incite violence keeps the
sick and drug-addicted on the streets
brands biology a phony construct and now
they want to make insults illegal they
also think the world's ending in ten
years with them running the asylum who
can say they're wrong Jesse yeah this
crime to say the B word I'm only doing
that for the producers I would have said
it but I'm I don't want the producer sad
you're welcome Megan this crime only
needs to be verified by what the person
being called a B word and a witness so
Dana and I could just set this up you
could say Jesse called you a B and I
could so I saw it and then I get to sit
there not really caught people into so
no but you get a wreck if you want to
switch
you would go to jail for we should do
that tomorrow six months you go to choke
and you pay a fine that's true a big
fine now listen Greg when the Pilgrims
landed did they they had no food yeah I
think they said son of a we gotta get
Sony or how about Lexington and Concord
the beginning of the American
Revolutionary War II got muskets flying
I think some bad words were using the
first governor of Massachusetts John
Hancock yeah is that gonna be a problem
how about this
the Patriots you know they're playing
the Jets Tom Brady's talking trash to
the defense making the Jets defense is
you know what is that gonna be a problem
if that gets picked up on the Mike's we
really gonna find Tom ridiculous that is
the sound argument thank you okay one
two students were arrested at UConn this
was another story for I think they said
the n-word we have the tape okay but
it's it's let's show the tape because if
you're not gonna hear anything anyway
but all right that's good they got
arrested but you have to agree I don't
think the first amendment has an
exception for insulting or even racist
speech right I'm a Juris I'm a big
proponent of the First Amendment but I
will say that when you have hate speech
in other words burning a cross on
someone's lawn that's an act yeah but
it's it's part it's considered hate
speech and it's an action what I mean if
you said this by the way I mean well
Jesse's talking about with Tom Brady you
know demeaning the defense that's not
what this is about this is about using
the language to intimidate insult and
that's why the woman went to her
politician is this needs to be legal
what am i right but but to my mind you
do have words that are fighting words
yeah so that can cause public harm that
you deaf you know you can't scream fire
in the crowd by the way how many people
shout fire in a crowded theater it
should be illegal you know this is what
happened with Westboro Baptist Church
remember of course they were allowed to
hold a protest at a military funeral
because they opposed the military's
acceptance of gay people but you know
what at some point the courts did say
hey you know what you can't interfere
and you got to stop you're you're
demeaning people in the midst of
expressing their grief you know what's
interesting about Westboro as repulsive
everything was at least they set a
standard it's like I think that's the
one you always like it's like that is so
patently awful but it's yes yeah so in
what's ironic too is that you have a
state like Massachusetts where you have
and it's bipartisan but mostly it's been
coming from the left that you should
reduce jail time yeah increase and also
you enlisted all the places where this
has originated and then has infected all
of our places but you forgot the United
Kingdom yes this actually happens in
Britain you can be arrested because Jess
you ever heard us talking and then now
that and then soon then we're
frog-marched out of Fox News or get
screwing up on pronouns and their list
is not just the be trip right their list
is anything you miss gender you miss
gender in Canada too but dr. Niccole the
swearing is therapy
it's actually it is cathartic everyone
juicing is cathartic and they actually
have been making small studies that
shows it releases endorphins and stress
relief and all the other things
this is encroaching on the First
Amendment it's a broad overstretch for
disorderly conduct and I think they need
to stay away from First Amendment rights
remember when Dana cursed on the show oh
yeah you know what you were saying truth
is a defense yeah anyway there's
something when a guy takes an alligator
and tapes his mouth and runs around a
convenience store scaring people he
should be called backward that work what
was that word hey